tous les soirs je quittais l'hôpital
vers 21h et ce soir là la dernière fois
à 18h30
les médecins m'ont demandé de partir
parce qu'ils m'ont dit faut que je me
repose parce que depuis le mois de
janvier j'étais tout le temps auprès de
lui jusqu'à 21h ils m'ont écouté on va
lui faire un examen
irm donc il va vous reposer c'est pas la
peine que vous l'accompagnez quand je
suis à banon mais il a l'habitude que je
la compagne parce qu'ils aiment passer
cet examen là et on dit non mais de
façon officielle du monde d'en bas et
tout allait vous reposez vous reviendrez
demain et c'est la seule fois là que
j'ai pas pu jamais juge lembras tout le
temps là j'étais au bout de son lipsky
avait plein de professeurs et je
remercierai jamais assez les professeurs
aussi à l'hôpital pompidou parce qu'ils
ont fait tout leur possible et
j'ai juste j'étais à ses pieds j'ai pris
ses pieds comme ça et j'ai jeté mon
chéri t'inquiète pas pour paulhan terme
pour pour l'enterrement de pardon pour
l'examen et tous les je suis là dès
demain t'inquiète pas t'inquiète pas et
c'est la première et la gelée pas serrer
dans mes bras comme je faisais tous les
soirs c'est ça qui est terrible et sa
sortie est moins que ces tutus moi je
savais que
juste je savais que j'y vois des
pressentiments va me dire que je suis
folle et tout ça mais je savais qu'il
passerait pas ses 72 ans
j'en ai parlé à ma meilleure amie petite
amie de ma fille avait dit quoi tu avais
10 juin il ya plus de dix ans je disais
j'ai très peur parce que je vois pas
jean pierre a fêté ses soixante douze
ans comment tu as eu ce flash et c'est
pas un flash c'est un truc à l'intérieur
c'est viscéral aux 72 ans que je voyais
c'est viscéral c'est comme si quelqu'un
me parle on ne parle pas j'entends pas
de voix mais c'est un truc qu'on le dit
72 ans va être compliqué 72 ans va être
compliqué et toujours moi c'était le
coeur et la tête et le coeur c'est
thrombose et avc massive voilà donc
c'est pour ça j'ai toujours à
jean-pierre t'inquiète pas tu ne mourras
pas d'un cancer tu mourras pas d'un
cancer mais j'ai jamais pu lui dire bien
sûr je voyais pas faire ces 72 heures
durant évidemment le viewer et donc
j'avais très peur quand il a commencé en
janvier à faire des avc ce qu'on fait en
tout il a fait 12 min avc et le 13e il a
été fatal
donc faut vous dire qu'il était puissant
effort et
et voilà il est enfin voila je savais
que ça serait plutôt le coeur et la tête
et je me suis pas trompé malheureusement
parce qu'il est mort juste avant ses 72
ans il est parti le 2 mars il allait
avoir 72 ans le 8 avril c'est fou c'est
fou
ça ça te stresse pas de savoir ça de
20,6 mais j'essaie toujours de me remet
à ma tête que je ne trompais toujours
une faune paix je vais me répéter il est
plus fort que ça nous la montrer à sa
puissance était le seul renfort ils
étaient vécus les faits il essayait de
se battre pour les autres gens qui
avaient le cancer il a été très fort je
suis mis à ses côtés parce qu'au début
ils avaient peur parler du cancer mais
je me suis battu pour quoi que ce soit à
bout et s'est rangée auprès de moi pour
voilà montrer le côté positif qu'il a
toujours montré et jusqu'au bout il a
été positif parce que même la veille de
son opération
il était fort bon il n'y avait pas dormi
de la nuit c'est évident ça tout le
monde peu de notions mais quand je lis
bon alors ça me fait penser à quoi une
femme j'ai réfléchi j'ai réfléchi je
fais mais la cua et ils me regardent
fait mon à plein de choses on se ferait
jouer à quoi tu penses alors je dis
surtout si tu arrive quoi que ce soit
n'oublie pas je sais que tu te moques de
moi quand je te parle de ça mais c'est
moi des signes j'ai dit sinon si tu ne
fais pas des signes dur et étranglée
donc j'ai dit la première chose qu'il
faudra que tu me fasses dessine et tu
verras quand tu partiras si jamais tu
dois partir
tu verras tu diras à merde elle avait
encore raison